today we are going to create a Twitter
bot that will post images of models onto
a Twitter account for us so this is what
we're going to end up with when we're
finished here on the left here we see a
script that is going to scrape a web
page for images and it will save them in
a folder for us on the right here we
have our Python bot script which is
going to go ahead and post those images
to our Twitter account at a set time
interval okay
so I'll run it for you guys so we can
see how it works here and then we're
going to go and review each line each
line of the code line by line so here is
what we're going to end up with well
this is the account I've got set up here
called the model bot and we're going to
send out our first tweet in just a
minute here so let's go ahead and get
this and get this script running so here
we have I'll show you guys right now I
have it set at a time interval of three
seconds so every three seconds is going
to tweet obviously if we were running
this on a separate server we would
change that time interval because
tweeting every three seconds might be
considered a little excessive but let's
go ahead and run this here so first off
I want to show you guys we'll run this
we'll run the script that'll scrape the
images first okay so let's go ahead I'm
going to show you guys the the desktop
here and just to show you so you can see
the folder that we've got so right here
we've got our empty folder or not empty
folder but we have our two scripts in
our folder so let's go ahead here and
now run our script that is going to get
the pictures for us okay so here we go
and so right now it is going to this web
page that we that I specified here and
it's pulling all the photos from that
web page and creating a folder that will
pop up in this in this directory here so
there you see our folder just got popped
up and now when we open it we have all
these pictures here from the website
that we scraped off the website off the
website alright so now that we've got
those pictures let's go ahead and run
our other script that is going to be the
Twitter bot for us okay so we've got
that and
now as we saw before don't currently
have any tweets for this for this
Twitter bot but now we're going to go
ahead and run this guy right here
alright and this is going to go ahead
and send out tweets for us at a three
second interval so let's go ahead and
refresh our page here and there we go
already got two tweets coming out and
refresh again another tweet and there we
go so again you can adjust that time
interval as you want depending on how
many tweets you want to send out and/or
what you're tweeting about okay so let's
go back and close out that script before
we get some serious Twitter overload
here and just one sec okay so there we
go that will finish that off so now
we're gonna review our scripts here and
so if you guys want to make this we're
gonna walk through step by step how you
would go about doing that and so we can
understand each line of the code here so
we'll start with how we scrape the
images from the web page so if depending
on what kind of Twitter bot you want to
make we can or you can use different
things so in this case I wanted it to
send out images but you can also do
third also Twitter BOTS that'll send out
any kind of thing so some do like poetry
some do memes some do a bunch of
different things so whatever you guys
want your Twitter bot to do or be you
want to go ahead and get that data that
it's going to that is going to be used
to send out those tweets so as far as
this script goes we'll review this one
quickly and then get over to the to the
bot itself well we have a URL here that
we are moving to and this is the URL
that has the pictures on it so you see
we can go to this quickly here and we'll
take a look at that alright so here's
the website and it is grabbing pictures
from this website here based there it is
based on our URL so it's grabbing these
pictures it's scraping these pictures
off the website and creating a folder
for us then saving them to that so we go
ahead we do that we're using the module
using the request module the
beautifulsoup module and the OS module
so in this case request is a module that
allows you to make requests to webpages
beautifulsoup is a module for kind of
downloading the HTML that makes up those
web pages so we can easily parse through
that and find what we want and then OS
is used to create the folder in the
directory that our scripts are in so
we've got that URL goes to that URL in
our next line here we have the page so
this is where we're actually requesting
the URL so we're requesting a response
from the server on that page and then we
are creating a our soup which is the
HTML that makes up that website that we
requested so once we get that we are
using the bs4 method find all which is
going to find all the images that are on
that web page for us and then it is
going ahead and we're going to create
the directory that we want to store
those images in okay so what this is
doing is it's saying if the models
folder does not exist in the folder that
we are currently in then we want to make
that folder and then otherwise we want
to just change our current directory to
that folder that we're in because when
your Python script saves files or saves
pictures in this case to the folder it's
going to save them unless you specify
otherwise to the current working
directory or the current folder that
you're in so we go ahead and we change
we change our current directory to the
models folder that we created so next up
here we have a variable that is going to
be used to Inc as we add our pictures we
want to specify them being slightly
different obviously because we don't
want to overwrite the same file as we
save our pictures so we have our x
equals 0 and we're going to increment
that for each picture in order to save
each picture as 1 2 3 etc ok so now we
have a loop here and what we're doing
with this loop is we are saying for each
image that is in our image tags soup
that we have here so this is returning
us a nice list of a nice list of image
tags and that but we don't have that's
just the raw HTML we don't we want to
extract the the source URL from each of
those as image elements ok so we're
going to go ahead here and so for each
image for each image in that list or for
each image HTML element that is in that
in that list then we want to go ahead
here and we want to get the source so we
were saying we're declaring a variable
called URL and we are setting that to be
the source of the image so in this case
we can reference the source attribute or
SRC attribute of the of the image tags
with our bs4 module by specifying the
image and then specifying within within
square brackets what the attribute that
we want to get is so then once we have
that URL we want to go ahead and we want
to navigate directly to that URL then we
want to go ahead and so if the source
status code equals 200 so if we get a
response there we want to go ahead and
we want to open up a new file and this
is the file that that is a jpg file so
you can see here with open model plus
string X so we have just the model text
plus the current value that our X
integer is app so remember we're
incrementing that in order to create new
create new image files and we want to
save that with the dot jpg extension and
then we want to be able to write to that
file so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to create that jpg file and
we want to specify that we're going to
write to it so then we're going to go
ahead and we're going to say F dot write
so what this is is it's opening up this
file and it's saying let's represent
this file that we opened up as as f so
we're gonna say F dot writes we want to
write to that file and then we want to
write the the request that we got the
content of the requests that we got so
that is what's going to capture the
image that loads when we navigate to
that URL after that we want to close the
file and then we want to increment X by
1 so we can move on to our next image
file so if at any point during that loop
there is some some exception thrown then
we just want to continue our loop with
the next picture because for some of
these images they won't always get a
proper request or there will be some
other small error that occurs
when we are navigating to that page that
the images is located on so if that is
the case that we want to go ahead and we
just want to pass over and pass over
that image and move to the next one okay
so that does it for our our image
scraping so now we're going to go ahead
here and talk about our model script so
this is the the script that creates our
Twitter bot so we're using three
libraries in this case we're using the
tweet P library which is a Python
library for accessing Twitter via the
API so in API is just an application
programming interface which is
essentially a lot of code that is
written to directly access certain data
within the within Twitter and to be able
to make certain to be able to form
certain operations such as posting new
status updates posting pictures
following and a bunch of other things
you can do on Twitter so we're going to
use the tweet P library in order to make
our code more efficient next up here we
have the time module which we are using
to specify how much time we want to rest
in between our tweets and then we have
the OS module in order to move over to
our folder that is that contains our
pictures that we scraped off the web so
next up here this is an important part
for creating this guys so we have the
credentials and the way what this is is
how you log in to your Twitter account
that your new Twitter bot account that
you created so if you guys are building
this go ahead and create a new account
on Twitter and then you want to go ahead
once you've created that account you
want to navigate over to this page here
so that's apps twitter.com backslash app
backslash new and just navigate to that
page and it's gonna bring this up here
so what this is is you need to create a
or you need to tell Twitter that you're
creating an application in order to get
in what are known as the API keys so you
can access your account directly through
the API interface that Twitter provides
so in this case you create a name for
your bot that you're creating you create
a description for your bot and then you
can just throw in any old website you
want if you want to go ahead and create
a website specific
for your bot go ahead and do that and
specify that there but otherwise go
ahead and throw in whatever website and
do make sure that you type in HTTP colon
backslash backslash not just ww-whatever
name of the website you are creating is
because otherwise it's gonna throw you a
little error there then you just go
ahead and check this off and create your
Twitter application so once you do that
you're gonna have access to a couple of
these keys here there is a tab that you
want to navigate to once you're within
that that will generate these keys for
you so you can access the Twitter API
from within your script so that'll give
you your consumer key your consumer
secret your access token and your access
secret so these are just long strings of
numbers and letters that are going to be
used to access your Twitter API so go
ahead and create variables to represent
those those keys and those secrets and
then go ahead and store those strings
within those variables so next up here
we're going to use a couple different
functions from the tweet P library in
order to log into our API so the first
one is the OAuth handler
so you see TP here which we set up at
the top here we want to import twe P as
TP so when we're referencing the tweet P
library from within our code we can
reference it just by the by TP instead
of having to type out what we P and so
we have TP dot o off handler which is
how we're going to log in to our or
authenticate with the Twitter server in
order to log in to our account so next
up here we want to take that off that
that value that we are representing with
auth and we want to go ahead and set the
access token again this is using a
function within the tweet P library and
that specifies two parameters which are
the access token and the access secret
so you go ahead and you add those in
there and then you have then you're
ready to login so your next line here is
to create the API variable and then go
ahead and login via the tweety api
function so again we specify TPA p i
with auth as our as our single parameter
and remember we set the consumer key the
consumer secret and the access token and
the access secret with these two lines
above
so now we've logged into our Twitter API
so what we want to do is post these
images so in this case we want to go
ahead and change the current directory
that we are in to the models folder that
we saved all our images that we scraped
in so in this case here we are using the
OS dot CH dir function which is
basically just saying change the current
folder that we are operating in to the
models folder so in this case your
script first starts running when it's
first runs it's it's the current
directory that it runs in is the
directory that the scripts themselves
are located in so remember we created
that folder in that same folder that the
scripts are in but now we want to move
into that folder that we created that
has the pictures so we're going to move
into that folder with that line and then
next up here we are going to loop over
the files that are within that folder in
order to post them each out of post each
each picture because in this case
they're going to be pictures at a set
time interval so we go ahead here and we
say 4 we're creating a variable called
model image which is going to represent
each file as we iterate over the files
that are within the folder that we
created and so we're gonna say for each
image that is in the or for model image
in the in the directory list so then
we're using the the list dir the list
der function that is part of the OS
module again which will list all the
files that are within our folder for us
so that allows us to iterate over them
and in this case we want to use again
that we key function which is the update
with media function so as far as this
goes there are a couple different
functions that you are there multiple
functions you can use for the different
things you want to do on Twitter with
Tweetie but in this case we want to use
the update with media function in order
to paste post a photo this can also be
used to post a video or post a gif so we
can go ahead and say update with media
another function you can use is update
status or update underscore status and
then you pass a string as your parameter
which is going to be just whatever text
you want to post say you just wanted to
send out a text-based
tweet you would use update status so
after we go ahead and we send out our
tweet then we want
go ahead and sleep so that's going to
tell our script to basically pause for
that amount of time and then continue
running so in this case we have our loop
that it's going to continue to run
continue to move through the folder that
contains our images and tweet them out
but in between each tweet this is where
you specify how much time you want how
much time there should be within between
each tweet so that's where you specify
this value here in seconds so in this
case it would be 3 seconds so that that
about does it for how to create the bots
and a couple things so moving forward
for this with you guys if you want to
create this go end or if you have
created this then the folder that we
created to store our images only has
about 14 or 15 images I believe I think
it's 14 from what whatever we scraped so
we've got those images but say you
wanted to continually post a new content
so what you would want to do here is
modify the script that scrapes the
pictures to continually scrape new
pictures or to at a certain time of the
day go ahead and request that URL again
and scrape the new pictures from the web
page and add them to that folder so we
can continue to iterate over new content
and we don't have to continue to say do
that by hand we can automate the entire
process so that would be how you could
move forward with this project and
create something that continues to
operate hands off so I hope you guys
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up and subscribe if you guys
haven't already any questions or
comments definitely leave them below
this is a kind of this is a cool project
to make and a great project to kind of
stretch your Python skills and uses a
bunch of different libraries and you are
using a few different functions to move
around your operating system which are
interesting to get a look at so yeah I
hope you guys enjoy